hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma inside the Ark
looks a whole lot comfier than this
place so the concept of the Ark is
apparently Lea know any up upload your
mind into something you're basically
making your own hemin heaven you make
the paradise that you would want your
brain consciousness to experience you
know if you can make your own world
which is kind of like the concept of the
matrix you know you make your own world
like you make whatever you want and
who's to say it won't be rejected okay
welcome if you're reading this you have
successfully entered the ark this survey
is designed to give the developers a
better understanding of your subjective
experience and now to improve your
well-being
please continue with the survey oh I
feel alien I'm a visitor inside another
body how would you describe your mental
condition I feel lost I don't exist
anymore how would you describe your
senses
I feel more sensitive to and aware of my
surroundings
I guess that one considering all the
things that I'm feeling how would you
describe the sensation of your new
condition it's disconcerting everything
feels constructed are you troubled by
the fact that you're no longer strictly
human see somewhat I feel like I lost
myself how would you perceive your new
existence I don't know it's a direct
continuation of my ayah that's actually
true for this guy it's a direct
continuation of my previous life do you
think this new existence will be a life
worth living maybe we can find a new
sense of meaning in this world would you
rather be removed from the project than
accept death maybe I need to think about
it give me give me a fifty-fifty chance
on that one your answer is I've been
saved cool I guess Oh
wonder if I thought of that does it
still work I really need to know what
happened to it
I think so it's doing something at least
I'm standing earth trying to find it
apparently I got lucky
Oh found it wow I'm really good at what
I do apparently okay so it's got to be
over here I would imagine it's over bifi
cuz that's what it was mentioned no I'm
not there how about Omega tau bing bada
bing bada boom I got it Wow
I'm shockingly good at this oh it
wouldn't be in the end would it
it sure would it sure would be in the
end was either the end of the beginning
but apparently I got it I found it it's
at a site named town if we got to it
could can we get on the ark oh okay I
guess the conversations done that I
guess we don't need to expand on that
any further I guess I don't need to have
a witty remark about how I can carry you
with me and then we can go together I
can't move
jump swim sort of you're stuck in the
door opener
the omni-tool I'll just carry you there
and you'll show me what to do
sounds really risky besides I don't like
the idea of you carrying me around come
on Catherine this is what you wanted to
do your final mission let's launch the
ark when we need to find a way to get
into the abyss can't date the climber
without a power suit we probably have to
go to fade ahead play that dumb bad
still working okay okay so we go to
theta I'm sure I'm chipper about all
this look around what else is there to
do you know what I found his sunken
vessel just outside bet that could take
us to theta
didn't look completely out of action it
even lit up a little when I tried the
omni-tool on okay
oh I would never could I actually know I
can't even get out the door without that
I'm gonna tell oh I'm gonna poke you or
I'm gonna fist yeah I've know it no I'm
gonna go with ya I know I know I don't
know what I'm doing with all these
pulsating rub over the holes probably
where all this robe of fluids come from
okay I'm coming can I pull the omni-tool
out wait wait okay just be sure to plug
me in again at some point why can you
not talk to me without it what I mean
it's supposed to be in AI aren't you
supposed to be able to do it to be all
chipper chatter with me okay so now that
I got her I should just be able to go
back out I am pretty sure I explored
everything there was something in here
that I missed but I highly doubt that
actually happened so like maybe I'm
absorbing power from those things and
that's the only way I'm gonna get to the
end of the game is if I absorb all of
them probably all right let's muse your
way down boop-boop
yay my favorite
soggy socks
all right let's go
I mean I don't know if this is gonna
work as perfectly as I imagined it's
gonna but I imagine is gonna go off
without a hitch
no one's gonna get in my way there's
gonna be no faulty equipment and
everything is gonna be great
we're gonna go to Robo heaven we're
gonna have a great time we're gonna be
man and wife
we're gonna make Robo babies and then
bubble butt is gonna live outside in a
little doghouse for Robo burro forever
that's gonna happen it's been it gonna
happen promise you what what is this
carry emergency vessel for aha hey can
you hear me I sure can how am i hearing
you underwater by the way that's
question I have
that's good sound I like that sound well
I was wrong to shop the CD came from
cherry it was a ship they used to make
runs between lambda and Lisbon looks
like their wreck is closed maybe you can
find a vessel like this one inside
sounds like a plan I'll just save the
security information and update the on
the tool okay cool thank you
I remember seeing a giant shipwreck
somewhere else maybe perhaps possibly it
was the one that I saw just do I need to
go that way I saw a shipwreck over that
way but I don't recall it being named
Puri is that like Madame Curie the
radiation pioneer lady well oh god this
is where I'm gonna go the wrong way well
I mean it would make sense that the game
wants me to progress forward and I don't
exactly recall there being an opening on
the ship records that I saw so why not
just follow this to my destiny because
maybe it's the right way to go it's not
a roller coaster cool I mean I'm
literally following a trail of lights I
don't exactly see how this could be any
less obvious of the go this way I don't
know if this is
I didn't do nothing I did nothing what
are you doing
what is happening am i okay am i dying
oh those are robofish oh hello well
alright then
apparently all organic matter has been
taken over by robots I don't know how or
why and I don't know why thinks we're
all shaking shimmy am i breathing why am
i breathing it's obvious that I'm a
robot
is this wreckage this one I'm doing
I wish bubble-butt was here I waited
bubble-butt was here to protect me from
the darkness is this one this looks like
it might be a thing
hello we would have Oh beep bop Boop
p.m. robot okay cool beans I guess
mium robo looking Miam robo use
flashlights anybody else in here I mean
the question of the day besides all the
other questions that I guess I kind of
got right is who put this suit together
and who downloaded it into this program
or downloaded my last brain scan into
this like who did that and also the
other question of the day is what are
the creatures that are shooting off so
much electromagnetism that they are you
know kind of infecting everyone and also
amy was still kind of alive back there
quote unquote so I mean what's
orchestrating all of the rogue robots
and what's orchestrating all the non
rogue robots I mean it seems to be
connected with the blue light that you
see on the bodies but that could just be
a coincidence because the robofish also
have those but also the body
no there's a thing at the top of hill
okay is he still there
hey I'm braver than you I'm tough I'll
punch you right in the Gabba swear on
Bubble Boy okay I think we're okay okay
then I mean we've barely even gotten
into the meat of this game I guarantee
you it's gonna get much worse much more
down the road what I mean it's a story
that's intriguing me anyway what I was
saying before is that the connection of
how those the electronics were like
forcing Amy to still be alive but also
we're like infecting her body with some
bizarre thing probably has a lot to do
with the Robo food scene everywhere I
just remember the game grumps bit about
foods every time I think about foods Hey
look is that a roboshark all right
Robo Music Robo Orchestra better not be
no Robo susan's I got bits of Robo
susan's I told you get off my back I
don't have time for it Robo keyboard
there better not be a robo cat on that
keyboard is this ship and question or is
this some kind of oil rig hello I might
just go towards this red glowing light
this doesn't look right but I've got
nowhere else to go so might as well
alrighty then are those red lights eyes
looking at me they'd better not be
hello special delivery I've got a girl
on an omni-tool you know what that means
no I don't
it's so weird I mean one I'm going into
this totally blind so I have no idea
what to expect but also like this game
has a lot of surprises to it and now I'm
just surprised as it turned I'm not
talking about jump scares I'm talking
about surprises in how deep and complex
that it's turning out to be okay that
just drops off into the abyss and I'm
not saying that it's the most complex
deep game that I've ever heard of but
I'm actually impressed at how advanced
like the story that they're going for is
like this is deep sci-fi this isn't even
totally sci-fi it's often philosophical
like the average gamer being expected to
understand philosophical concepts like
okay never mind that I won't close it
thank you
weird okay then I guess we're loading
alright alright let's find a working
song okay thank you talking to myself
you know Katherine can't hear you right
because she's in an omni-tool
anyway yeah so getting getting average
gamers to understand like concepts such
as this is actually I'm actually quite
proud that they're doing it like I'm not
saying it's a bad thing in any way I'm
saying it's very very good thing like
don't just challenge people in terms of
gameplay but also challenge people in
terms of understanding and like trying
to wrap their heads around advanced
concepts you know it makes people cure
hey bones oh hey how's it going
okay put Toby Mik fryer okay that's
still working wow this these electronics
were definitely built to last unless all
this is an illusion too maybe there's
some corrupt version of the ark whoa
okay never mind never mind never mind
I'm sorry I'm sorry
he's gonna kill me I'm gonna die I don't
understand that enemy I don't understand
how it works
I'm guessing I just don't look at it and
then I'll be a-okay but how is that even
fair humming how would I even know
you're just like I say Randy oh good
it's on fire everything is on fire
okay so apparently they sent an
exploratory to God okay that's not good
this I could open open open open open
open oh thank you Oh God oh I gotta run
away from this thing all exploring good
[ __ ] you I don't like it I don't like
that thing I don't like that thing I
don't like that thing I don't like that
thing Oh God dead end I probably just
going into it there it is found thing I
found the thing I was supposed to find I
think
what do we get what are we go and he's
here it's a third is notes things is it
still after me holy hell I mean it's not
exactly moving fast but an ego rapture
drug okay I don't know what this is oh
that's locked okay it's bad I'm gonna
die I wanna die hello fishy simon's more
scared than I am oh no oh no no no okay
look at don't look at
Hey
okay cool that's how we're gonna do it
huh was that Oh catcher's mitt okay so I
lowered a ladder over there it's gotta
go I gotta get to it I gotta get it back
I'm just going for it I'm going for it
Lazarus right here ladders right here go
go go jump go go go go go quicker
quicker quicker go what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
why would you do that why would you jump
off ladder when you were trying to go up
it why would you do that was I my fault
probably probably accidentally double
clicked on it okay there's a whole bunch
of fun I love this super fun all of
those oh man like I said just kind of
get more fun from here on out it's a
whole barrel of laughs is that a
different one that's no that's the same
one all right so nothing over here
hmmm I wonder if there's gonna be
another one exploring this area up here
owner if there's another butthole that
needs a fisting little body
oh no that's a shirt okay boof I thought
I was gonna be spooked for a second
there but apparently everything's okay
all right yeah that's the sound of
something isn't
oh crap that's Pleasant that that's
there oh okay all right he's right there
he's exactly where I need to go where do
I which ways go please go
he's going that way
attention this is your captain speaking
the final effort to disturb the comet
has officially failed
okay all right I think we're okay thanks
captain you're the best all right so
everything that they tried to do failed
in terms of stopping the comment we do
have a lot of creative ideas for that
because it is a world ending fear oh
hopefully by the time we get to 2103
we'll actually have something to do
about it why is this not glowed up why
is it's not glowy
wait this is a butthole I know what to
do when I get to a butthole why is that
not glowy at all okay I guess not maybe
not that one
maybe there's something else I missed
maybe there's gonna be something here I
don't exactly know what I'm looking for
besides the submersible which could be
anywhere why isn't this one over here
this seems like a secret area where I
could have gone to something and found
it but apparently not alrighty then
maybe because it only needed me to find
one in this area and I found one so are
we having all right so now I need to go
I just came up I just need to make sure
I got absolutely everything I do not
want to overlook something because then
people would yell at me for a long
okay we'll get here I mean I don't even
know like if the lay it doesn't actually
seem like the ship is tilted on its side
sometimes but sometimes it definitely
does seem like it's just all topsy-turvy
okay what is this
this seemed important apparently I'm
sitting over here ah I need this thank
you pull an efficiency reactor temps
Teddy oh man I didn't want to do
anything bad
I just wanted to poke my fingers into
some strange places
oh my brain Oh God
that's a good boy actor claps
beforehand maybe I'm supposed to find it
before it is it after me oh it's after
me isn't it oh this ain't good
oh that's not good hide I'd press any
button to try again whoop-dee-doo nah
apparently I died for the first time
which was bound to happen that guy was
after me I just don't know
it's not gonna be the right way
well I mean maybe I'm oh there's a
lighted like a lighted corridor is that
guiding me
I think it's gonna pretty sure it's
guiding okay it's got to be hiding me
it's gotta be
can you steer this thing starboard
rudder is joking but I can compensate
how do you even know what direction
we're going in don't worry I loved up to
the navigator
we're headed for theta should be a
matter of minutes I thought I was done
for back there seems like the WoW is
keeping the curing from going into a
catastrophic failure state I mean how do
you get on the ship are you talking
about the black tentacles in the engine
room I've seen them before it Upsilon
what are they they're a manifestation of
a malfunctioning station wide artificial
intelligence called the Wow
all right then station wide so we just
made a powerful enemy no no it's not
like that the AI is their persona it
doesn't feel or think like we do it's
more like it's boiling a cancer was that
the ship looks like your sabotage worked
better than expected
I'm sure glad I could see all the
spectacular cinematic adventure that
that was but I understand why do ok
here's the thing well actually maybe
there's probably to be more words but
okay thank you Madame Catherine are you
okay oh let me just get up here my robo
legs are awfully stiff and my Robo rein
in the underwater hello Catherine you
okay okay then so what happened there
and why I screwed up is because I
remember seeing that hallway big shining
lights and red lights going towards it
practically going mark look at me I'm a
vessel if you plug me in you didn't know
what to do but I saw that and I went
that's too obvious
it's trying to trick me I'm Way too
smart to be fooled by the likes of that
I'll just blaze forward blindly and then
start tugging on tentacles and shoving
my fist in places they shouldn't be
shoved cuz that's how mark rolls baby
woo anyway so that's all the time that I
have for this episode I'll figure out
where we are in the next one thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
that's how you're gonna play this game a
game baby I'm home come out and scooty
oh boy